ceux qui n'aiment pas la poésie mais qui
aime le brut de décoffrage a dit qu'il
n'aime pas la suggestion mais qui aime
l'exposition totale
nous allons leur dieu que nous aimons
nous la sujétion c'est par cette petite
introduction qu olivier bérisson mène la
petite troupe jusqu'à la plage de lens
moustiques petite troupe d'une quinzaine
de personnes
car malgré l'appel lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux et les centaines de commentaires
laissés par des internautes outrés par
le nudisme sur les plages martiniquaises
le grand public n'avait pas répondu à
l'appel ce dimanche à lens moustiques
l'ambiance était familiale
mais après une courte marche jusqu'à
petite céline changement d'ambiance
monsieur c'était une blague à tabac
avis à vous
or dix avouent à bien vous avez à vous
cette plage pour vous elles étaient
accessibles onudi
ouais parce que c'est isolé désolé on
cherche d'être isolé il est très calme
on évite justement les autres plages où
il ya des familles mais c'est le mans ou
si on passe par là où j'habite c'est
vivre s'il vous plaît mais l'opération
va légèrement se corser car les nudistes
présents sur la plage ne vont pas
forcément apprécié le rappel à l'ordre
parfois très vifs de la délégation
d'olivier benso
qui permet à ces gens de se promener
comme il sonné c'est pas possible
nous ne pouvons pas continuer comme ça
rendez vous compte que nous venons ici
avec nos enfants alors mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
la pinte de lait ya une loi leur loi
toudic à la biture lé public
est ce que dans les lieux publics il est
permis de se mettre tout nu
il me semble pour rappel sasp a atteint
deux attentats à la pudeur
jma exhibitionnisme et c'est d'ailleurs
nous nous réservons le droit de porter
plainte pour exhibitionnisme là
aujourd'hui
d'accord donc nous nous excusons ainsi
nous avons ôté les oreilles de ses côtés
mais leurs appareils génitaux nous
orienter d'autres opérations du même
type sont déjà prévus sur cette plage et
sur d'autres en semaine et le week-end